bom dia o que é genética
só um minutinho desculpa
o que a genética fala sobre você e sobre
a sua saúde
primeiro o que é dna é uma sequência de
apenas quatro letras chamados
nucleotídeos que são complementares
a t c e g hoje crianças de 7 e 8 anos já
reconhecem a molécula de dna
um estudo realizado nos estados unidos
com crianças mostrou que a molécula do
dna é tão conhecida quanto a marca o
símbolo da coca cola e do mac donald's
nós também vimos isso com as nossas
crianças brasileiras
um estudo que realizamos nas escolas
públicas o projecto ezzra pej
a gente faz a extração de dna do morango
com as crianças e quando mostramos a
molécula do dna
todas respondem rapidamente de forma
correta
eu quando era criança eu não sabia o que
era dna e acredito que muitos aqui
presentes que nasceram antes da década
de 80 também não sabiam estou certa eu
me apaixonei pela genética no primeiro
ano da faculdade
há 20 anos atrás com a professora que
fazia parte do projeto genoma humano 18
países inclusive o brasil fizeram parte
do consórcio público que determinou toda
a seqüência do dna humano esse projeto
encerrou em 2003 agora uma curiosidade
só que entre nós mulheres vocês sabiam
que o principal experimento que permitiu
de escrever que o dna uma dupla hélice
foi feito por uma mulher a rosalinda
franklin
só que quem ganhou o nobel em 62 pelo
feito foram três homens
watson o click e o chefe da rosa linda
é mole
mas hoje todo mundo tem acesso às
informações do dna
elas são públicas qualquer pessoa pode
acessar sua própria seqüência de dna e
essa ferramenta tem sido explorada pelas
empresas têm se tornado uma ferramenta
de negócio às empresas de biotecnologia
têm explorado as informações do dna pra
prestar serviços testes que determinam
por exemplo predisposição de 200 doenças
como diabetes alzheimer diferentes tipos
de câncer
essa empresa que oferece esse tipo de
serviço ela também informa sobre
ancestralidade do indivíduo
quem nunca teve condições curiosidade de
saber sobre os seus antepassados
eu também tive quando eu trabalhava no
inca estudando genes associados com
efeito de medicamentos e com a
centralidade do povo brasileiro eu
também fiz meu teste genético e descobri
que nós brasileiros por baixo da pele
somos todos misturados uma mistura de
índios africanos e europeus
e essa mistura genética da população
brasileira é a maior riqueza do nosso
povo durante o mestrado a gente
identificou uma mutação que até então só
tinha sido descrita em populações
africanas
essa mutação confere o metabolismo lento
para diversos medicamentos que são
clinicamente relevantes e que são
utilizados hoje na prática clínica
dependendo do medicamento que esse
paciente esse indivíduo tomar
com essa votação ele pode ter uma
intoxicação um efeito adverso grave e
até vir a óbito
o que fazer então com essa informação
será que devemos produzir medicamentos
para subgrupos étnicos de acordo com a
cor da pele do indivíduo não mas saibam
que isso já aconteceu em 2005 nos
estados unidos foi aprovado um
medicamento para a insuficiência
cardíaca apenas para pacientes que se
autodeclaram negros são um absurdo
ocorreu um erro no ensaio clínico e esse
medicamento rapidamente foi retirado do
mercado
isso também cria um novo paradigma para
a indústria farmacêutica porque precisa
produzir medicamentos para subgrupos de
pacientes porque é porque os
medicamentos mais eficazes são os
analgésicos uma classe simples de
medicamentos e mesmo assim apenas 60% da
população responde o tratamento com a
aspirina uma dipirona os medicamentos
menos eficazes são os que mil terá picos
apenas 25% da população responde ao
tratamento
hoje existem medicamentos que foram
criados na era do dna da biologia
molecular e preconizando a aplicação da
medicina personalizada
um grande exemplo o primeiro medicamento
produzido na era do dna é pra tratar 20%
das mulheres que apresentam um câncer de
mama e que super expressam receptores r
essas mulheres hoje possui um tratamento
eficaz específico para esses subtipos de
câncer de mama
o fnde que é o órgão que regulamenta a
venda de medicamentos e alimentos nos
estados unidos similar ão vivo aqui no
brasil aprovou o uso de testes genéticos
para 261 medicamentos
esses medicamentos são utilizados para
tratar o hiv doenças psiquiátricas
cardíacas diferentes tipos de câncer
dentre esses medicamentos
está o anticoagulante oral varfarina que
utilizados para pacientes que possuem
problemas no coração que utilizam alguma
prótese cardíaca ou que apresentam
fibrilação atrial
desde 2007 o fnde aprovou o uso de teste
genético antes do início do tratamento
com warfarina o tratamento com esse
medicamento é extremamente complicado
porque qualquer variação na dose o
indivíduo pode ter um sangramento uma
hemorragia ou o efeito oposto uma
trombose até mesmo um avc e vir a óbito
na bula da varfarina existe a
recomendação da necessidade de se
realizar um teste genético antes do
início do tratamento
alguém faz esse teste aqui no brasil não
e nem a minha mãe fez quando iniciou o
tratamento com warfarina apesar de ter
sido tema da minha tese de doutorado a
varfarina e os testes genéticos que eu
defendi em 2009
em 2017 a minha mãe teve um avc
até hoje o nosso grupo continua
publicando em revistas internacionais de
alto impacto sobre a importância dos
testes genéticos no tratamento com
warfarina a varfarina custa 5 reais
os testes genéticos ainda são muito
caros para a qual o medicamento então
que hoje na prática clínica os testes
genéticos são feitos antes de iniciar um
tratamento principalmente na área de
oncologia no tratamento do câncer
hoje antes de iniciar o tratamento de um
câncer de pulmão de intestino de ovário
é necessário fazer um teste genético
para determinar o subtipo de tumor
daquele paciente e utilizar medicação
que é eficaz para aquele indivíduo
para vocês terem uma idéia o teste
se o custo do teste genético no
tratamento do câncer do pulmão em torno
de dois mil reais aqui no brasil isso já
é feito o teste que identifica para a
exposição de aproximadamente 200 doenças
a ancestralidade do indivíduo e outras
informações interessantes que eu vou
falar a seguir quando a empresa foi
criada lá no vale do silício o teste
custava mil dólares
hoje custa 99 dólares e qualquer um que
puder pagar pelo teste pode fazer o
resultado do teste enviado por e mail
imaginem um leigo sozinho em casa se
deparando com o resultado de um teste
que tem 90% de chance de desenvolver
câncer
são informações extremamente complexas é
necessário um aconselhamento genético
profissionais capacitados que possam
orientar esse indivíduo a facilidade aos
testes genéticos não significa que toda
a população deva fazer
mas esse teste genético também é
interessante saber por exemplo como você
metaboliza cafeína o álcool ea nicotina
isso pode explicar porque algumas
pessoas tomam tanto café e não sofrem os
efeitos adversos da cafeína
provavelmente porque o metabolizado
rápido pode explicar por que o número de
cigarros que o indivíduo fuma ou até
mesmo hábito vício desse indivíduo de
fumar pode explicar porque algumas
pessoas tomam apenas uma taça de vinho e
já ficam autorizadas
provavelmente porque apresenta uma
mutação no gene que codifica enzimas
álcool desidrogenase responsável pelo
metabolismo do álcool um teste genético
também é legal saber
sobre o seu perfil nutricional uma
empresa em são paulo hoje vem de um
teste por r$300 que informa sobre o
sobre o seu perfil genético nutricional
e ainda indica a dieta adequada pra você
agora imaginem se eu descubro que eu
tenho uma mutação que eu não vou
engordar e seu começo comer chocolate de
forma descontrolada
com certeza vou desenvolver diabetes com
teste genético também é legal saber
sobre o seu perfil atlético será que o
meu perfil é de resistência para correr
uma maratona ou eu tenho o perfil de
velocista correu os 100 metros como bolt
nós também temos um projeto com atletas
aqui no entanto já recrutamos mais de
800 atletas
nós buscamos alterações genéticas que
podem predizer o aparecimento de uma
lesão no atleta
a idéia é desenvolver um algoritmo e com
isso direcionar contra um treinamento
individualizado para aquele atleta
talvez a antecipar um diagnóstico e até
mesmo orientar um tratamento mas
imaginem se os clubes começam contratar
os atletas agora com base no perfil
genético será que o ronaldo o fenômeno
que era uma incógnita ia ser convocado
para a copa de 2002
e será que o brasil a ser campeão
mundial
não é apenas o componente genético que
vai determinar uma doença ou uma pit dão
existe a influência do ambiente que é
estudado na epigenética hoje os
algoritmos são uma realidade cada
variável de indivíduo independente mente
de ser genético ou não ganha um peso um
valor
nessa fórmula e vai informar o risco de
um indivíduo desenvolver determinada
doença ou de ter o efeito desejado com o
tratamento farmacológico para vocês
terem uma ideia hoje o custo para
determinar todas as mutações no gene
brca1 e brca2 que estão associados com
risco de desenvolvimento de câncer de
ovário e de mama hereditário
o mesmo teste que angelina jolie fez
isso e retirou as mamas e ovário
o custo é de 3 mil dólares mas imaginem
se ao invés de retirar um órgão se a
gente pudesse consertar o dna
no futuro talvez teremos as cirurgias
genéticas
hoje isso é possível em um laboratório
com ferramentas de engenharia genética
você consegue consertar de forma precisa
uma seqüência de dna
o cristo é uma ferramenta de engenharia
genética e nada mais é do que a defesa
da bactéria contra infecção por vírus
as ferramentas de engenharia genética
também permite que nós sejamos os
arquitetos dos nossos filhos
imaginem a busca do bebê perfeito
escolheu o sexo a cor dos olhos um bebê
sem nenhuma mutação será eugénie a
nazista retornando
precisamos discutir questões éticas
sociais e legais
é preciso a criação de leis
quem tem direito à informação que está
no meu no seu dna
e pra finalizar eu gostaria que vocês
prestassem atenção nessa palavra a
genética que dentro dela tem outra
palavra escondida a ética
obrigada
[Aplausos]